in case you haven't heard the boys is
finally back on amazon prime video
that's right the hotly anticipated
second season of amazon's hyper violent
giddily nihilistic anti-superhero
dramedy is officially underway
rolling out episodes weekly after
premiering the first three episodes on
september 4th
that means the boys fans are finally
getting a look at what's become of the
show's ragtag cast in the wake of that
bruising season 1 finale
season 1 of the satirical series ran in
2019 and proceeded to push the
boundaries of abusive language
graphic violence and shocking twists in
ways no one could have anticipated
season two promises more of the same
though it's also set to drop a few new
faces into the action
one of which will be an electrokinetic
super by the name of stormfront
i'm the new girl wait what are you
talking about
hi i'm in the seven replacing
translucent
yes there's a pretty good chance the
actor portraying stormfront will look a
bit familiar to you her name is aya cash
and she's been a legit rising star
in film and television over the past
decade if ayakash does look familiar to
you it's likely because you're a fan of
epx's anti-romantic dramedy you're the
worst
that series premiered on the cable
network back in 2014 and proceeded to
air for five seasons on fx
over that period you're the worst became
a bit of a cult hit for fx
serving as a hilarious heartbreaking and
often all too real exploration of the
pitfalls of relationships in the modern
age
whether in a week or 20 years there is
horrible sadness and pain coming and
we're inviting it
got out of the way you think aya cash
was at the center of the action for most
of the 62 episodes of you're the worst
appearing as gretchen a self-obsessed
music publicist and one half of the
couple at the heart of the series
gretchen meets her romantic counterpart
the equally self-obsessed writer jimmy
played by chris gear and you're the
worst pilot episode after he's been
kicked out of his ex's wedding reception
for causing a scene
anyway gretchen and jimmy hit it off in
the parking lot and the series charts
the dramatic highs and punishing lows of
their relationship moving forward
along the way aya cash more than
delivered the comedic and dramatic goods
as gretchen trapped in a character as
casually manipulative
and preposterously self-serving as she
is unexpectedly nurturing
and tragically insecure in doing so
she's also crafted one of the more
memorable characters in modern
television
one that rightfully served as ayat
cash's breakout role to boot
while 2019 brought a fitting end to
ayakash's momentous run on you're the
worst it also saw the actor land another
prime gig with her fx bosses
this one cast her opposite michelle
williams and sam rockwell on the cable
giant's critically allotted limited
series event fossey verdin
fossey verdin found rockwell and
williams dancing into the title roles as
famed choreographer
director bob fosse and his equally
talented romantic and creative partner
the legendary broadway star gwen verdin
if you're wondering where aya cash slots
into the action she turns up in six of
fosse verdin's eight episodes as joan
simon a former dancer and wife of
legendary playwright neil simon
joan simon was also gwen verdin's
closest friend and confidant
until bone cancer took her life in 1973.
needless to say
such a dramatic character arc gave aya
cash one of her juiciest roles yet
every marriage goes through rough
patches
not yours i threw a frozen veal chop at
neil's head last week
you may not realize it but ayakash has
been acting professionally since 2006
appearing on three different law and
order series over the years
that being said we're guessing most
viewers first took notice of the rising
star later that same year
around the time she turned up in the
wolf of wall street as janet the
hilariously outspoken assistant to
leonardo dicaprio's debauched 90s money
man jordan belfort
your dad's coming something about the
american express bill can you get him
out of here
yeah lick my no i'm serious clearly cash
has built a hefty diverse resume with
the boys pushing her even further into
the well-deserved spotlight
her next project set for release on
october 1st 2020
is scare me the directorial debut from
josh rubin a writer producer actor
comedian who also appeared on you're the
worst
ruben stars as fred and cash stars as
franny two writers in a tale about
strangers sharing scary stories during a
power outage
that seems like relatively tame fair but
the horror kicks in when the exchange
tales start to bring out the worst in
the scribes
scare me also stars comedians chris redd
and rebecca drysdale as carlo and
bettina respectively
after premiering at the sundance film
festival in late july 2020 scare me will
hit the shutter streaming service on
october 1st
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff for coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one